this is like war stop oh no Skyy oh [ __ ]
I hate corridors you can never trust
them ever never trust them corridors
ever ever [ __ ]
oh I don't want to be patient I want to
be measure how are you [ __ ] kidding
me
be patient suck my dick [ __ ] so that's
how you did it
oh [ __ ] is still here oh I don't just
yet get up get up c'mon our memory
you're bugging me yeah I know you ran
here huh we can go here [ __ ]
oh no look at this Peter Sousa look at
that penis oh okay okay okay that's
looking he's like oh you look at my
babies eyeball Gilly oh okay okay it's
not like I had his penis replaceable
Oh
oh man Oh [ __ ] man ah
I saw his penis it was freaking huge oh
come on beer bro Stefano really okay
just take it to Leigh Leigh nice and
quiet don't make noises huh okay this
way for thee um it's this drunk don't
worry
you just drank too much look you track
from those Oh daddy don't that to our
work here but well sheriff's everywhere
but I need some Oh nope
but the fog is going and I can go there
let's oh [ __ ] what I light that up
before okay just no no no sofa no
sofa share mode activated okay
don't leave me like this don't wait up
we're close the door oh okay
pull the lever pull it over you don't
let you have a lot of time you have a
lot of time a lot of time help me mr.
Sherr help me I don't even know anymore
oh it's wagging Betty run I'm chaining
um adju let's go here
oh hey sexy hahaha oh man I'm in a game
look at me I'm in a game mom look dad
Hey look at this that's on me that's
right that's right it's only that photo
not that
you
go broken lock maybe this maybe this yes
yes yes come on pull it Jesus yes
crowbar broke how the [ __ ] are you
kidding me are you kidding me but look
that way were they why I don't
understand no oh my crowbar white wow
how can it break from wood how can I
know I missed ah I was so happy
ah oh that right though why are you
walking there I need to go there
okay I'm just gonna go here when you
show your penis to those oh oh man ha ha
how's it going my bros my name is Pierre
ba I hope you enjoyed these moments if
you did as always please guys add them
to your favorites and like it and if
you're not a subscriber yet then why not
become a bro today and don't miss out on
these moments we had a great week this
time there was a lot of moments that I
had that I couldn't fit in this montage
also guys I'm launching my second
channel I will not be uploading videos
to this channel for a week because I'm
going away to Italy to see my girlfriend
and then she is coming back the 25th to
celebrate no sorry to move in with me
I'm going really to celebrate my
birthday with it which is the 21st
fourth 24th of October my girlfriend's
is at the 21st but anyway so click on
the screen now if you want to go to my
long channel and go over there subscribe
as well I will be updating you guys on
what's going on and I will keep doing
Long's this whole time that's a plan to
have two channels running at the same
time so if you're into that kind of
stuff then go over there and subscribe
and I spent my entire night it's 7:00 in
the morning editing this please guys
share this video everywhere it
really helped me out a lot and I would
brofist then bro-hug get all of you if
you did so anyway that's pretty much it
haha